[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a post-apocalyptic horror
film called 28 days later
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with a group of radical
animal rights activists storming into a
laboratory the lab has held different
species of chimpanzees in captivity for
medical research the radical activists
proceed to free the animals but a lab
staffer warns the group against it
alleging that the animals are infected
with the highly infectious rage virus
however the animal rights activists do
not heed his advice and start releasing
the chimps lo and behold as soon as the
chimps are released they violently start
attacking everyone in the lab infecting
them in the process the lab staffer
tries killing the infected but it's too
late and he easily gets overpowered the
infection spreads rapidly through the
activists and turns them into
uncontrollable monsters in a matter of
20 seconds the movie then fast forwards
to 28 days in the future a man named jim
wakes up in a hospital bed as he gets up
from his bed and looks around he
realizes that the hospital is deserted
and trashed all phone lines are dead he
grabs a beverage and heads out only to
realize that the entire city of london
is deserted and seems like it underwent
some sort of catastrophe much like the
hospital he wanders through the city
hoping to find other people he comes
across a church where a large group of
people have gathered he calls out for
them only to get chased by people who
seem to have turned into raging monsters
they follow jim into the streets until
he runs into two survivors selena and
mark the duo throw diy petrol bombs at
the raging monsters setting them on fire
they then finish the monsters off by
using explosives and lead jim into their
hideout a shop in the london underground
it is revealed that jim is a bicycle
courier who met with an accident and
went into a coma while he was in a coma
the rage virus uncontrollably spread
throughout the country turning people
into violent monsters and resulting in a
societal collapse
there's no radio electricity tv
government army or police and all that's
left for consumption is candies and
canned soft drinks selena speculates
that the catastrophe has gone global the
revelation alarms jim and he insists on
finding his parents selena and mark try
to advise him against it but eventually
relent and accompany him to his parents
home the next morning much like the
entire city jim's home seems haunted he
finds his parents dead bodies in their
room they seem to have committed suicide
together and have left a final note for
him
jim breaks into tears after reading the
note for safety reasons the trio decide
to spend the night in jim's home and
sleep in the same room the thought of
his parents doesn't let jim sleep as
selena and mark peacefully sleep jim
looks at his mother's handwriting and
old home videos suddenly two monsters
break into his home from the window and
attack him like raging maniacs selena
and mark quickly wake up and come to
jim's rescue and the monsters are
quickly neutralized jim survives without
injury but mark is bleeding from the
fight fearing a possible infection
selena quickly knocks mark down and
hacks him to death with a machete as jim
watches in horror selena decides to
immediately leave for the store fearing
more possible attacks jim is shaken by
mark's murder but selena explains to him
that the virus spreads through
contaminated blood overtaking the
victims in a matter of seconds and
turning them into raging violent
monsters she believes that just being
alive is enough and the end justifies
the means she warns him that if he ever
gets infected she would kill him in a
heartbeat as they head to the store they
notice christmas lights blinking in an
apartment window in a high-rise building
in an otherwise dark and desolate city
they get hopeful of finding other
survivors and go to investigate they
take the stairs to the apartment but
halfway through their journey jim
suffers from fatigue and extreme
headache possibly due to hunger she
proceeds to pass in painkillers and a
drink but suddenly they hear sounds of
infected people climbing the stairs
panicking the duo run upstairs and run
into a man in police riot gear the man
directs the pair to his apartment while
he blocks the infected the infected try
to get past him but the man manages to
neutralize them the man then welcomes
the two to their apartment and
introduces himself as frank he lives
with his teenage daughter hannah he
offers them some wine and turns off the
battery run christmas lights selena and
jim spend the night at frank's flat and
privately discuss whether they should
stay with them jim believes that they
are good people but selena thinks that
they will slow them down and she would
leave them behind in a heartbeat
selena's kind of a dick about this
heartbeat thing she warns jim that
putting others above one's survival is a
guaranteed way of getting killed the
next morning frank and jim check the
water they have left the situation isn't
looking good as it has not rained in
days and frank believes they won't be
able to survive for long hold up in the
apartment he then shows jim and selena a
recording of a radio broadcast
transmitted by soldiers the soldiers
stationed near manchester claimed to
have found the answer to the infection
and are calling survivors to come find
them frank suggests they head to
manchester selena initially hesitates
but eventually agrees the group then
heads out in frank's car during their
journey they come across a tunnel jim is
skeptical of passing through a dark
tunnel but frank and selena veto him and
head into the tunnel the tunnel is
blocked by a pile of car debris and
frank drives over it resulting in a flat
tire jim's worst fear comes true and the
group hears a bunch of infected people
running towards them frank and the
others team up and frantically changed
the tire just managing to escape in time
after traveling some distance they
stopped to stock up on food and other
essential supplies they also fill up a
large jerry can with fuel for their long
journey the group spends the night in a
pastoral field and have dinner together
after spending time with frank and his
daughter selena's opinion about life
begins to change she admits to jim that
just being alive isn't enough and there
is more to life
afraid of being attacked jim and hannah
have a hard time falling asleep while
selena easily dozes off jim wakes her
and asks her to share her secret selena
passes them pills that she takes to fall
asleep she reveals that she is a
qualified chemist and the pills are safe
that's what they all say jim and hannah
take one each and fall asleep while
frank stays up to watch out for the
infected monsters the next morning they
continue their journey after driving for
hours they reach a blockade they also
notice fires engulfing manchester in the
distance to their dismay they learn that
the blockade is deserted selena suggests
they should return home but frank isn't
ready to give up he looks around for
soldiers but eventually loses hope he
starts getting agitated and screams at
the others in frustration a cawing crow
feeding on an infected soldier's corpse
adds to his frustration
frank kicks on the tin wall and tries to
ward off the bird but a drop of
contaminated blood lands in his eyes
instead
realizing that he has been infected
frank tells his daughter to keep away
from him but hannah only grows worried
and walks towards him as the virus
begins to take over frank's body selena
quickly stops hannah while frank is shot
dead by soldiers hidden behind the
blockade it turns out the blockade
wasn't deserted after all the soldiers
take the three survivors and their car
to a fortified mansion they are greeted
by mayor henry west who is commanding
the soldiers the trio take showers and
change into clean clothes frank's death
and its impact on hannah affects selena
who has grown close to both over the
past few days
jim comforts selena and they start
developing romantic feelings for each
other jim later talks to west about the
answer to infection they were promised
in the army broadcast west assures him
that it may not be what he had imagined
but they do have an answer the mansion
is surrounded by high perimeter walls
and the surrounding ground has been
laced with tripwires and landmines they
use wood fire to get hot water and cook
food west is also counting on the
infected people to starve to death he
even keeps an infected soldier named
mailer chained in the mansion in order
to study the effects of the virus
everyone then gathers for dinner as
people eat whatever the soldier cook has
managed to put together west has
disagreements with his sergeant farrell
over post-infection life after dinner
west takes jim for a drink west gives
him a lecture about survival before
revealing that he had promised to
provide women to his soldiers the
soldiers aren't just waiting for the
infected to die they also plan to
survive by forcing sexual servitude on
the female survivors alarmed by the
revelation jim attempts to flee with
selena and hannah sgt farrell tries to
help them but unfortunately the soldiers
easily capture them and lock farrell and
jim in a room while imprisoned farrell
speculates that the virus must not have
spread beyond british borders he points
out that the virus takes over one's body
so fast that it would be impossible for
the infected to flee the island and
spread the disease the following day two
soldiers take farrell and jim into the
woods to execute them when one of the
soldiers named jones hesitates to shoot
his sergeant the other soldier shoots
feral for him this angers jones and he
fights with the other soldier while jim
runs off he crosses over the wall and
manages to get away on the other side he
notices the contrails of a plane flying
overhead and becomes hopeful meanwhile
selena and hannah are ordered by west to
become presentable to serve the soldiers
and are taken to a washroom selena
convinces the soldiers to give her some
time to prepare hannah suddenly the
sirens start going off west learns that
jim had managed to flee and heads out to
hunt him with one of his soldiers jim
ambushes the soldier near the blockade
and kills him he then steals his gun and
runs back to the mansion at the
headquarters jim releases the infected
soldier mailer from captivity mailer
attacks the soldiers and the two girls
manage to flee but selena gets captured
by another soldier mailer's bite creates
another monster and they start attacking
other soldiers jim also takes out a
soldier and looks for the girls as west
returns
jim violently kills the soldier who has
held selena hostage as she watches in
horror fearing that he might be infected
selena grabs her machete and proceeds to
strike him but can't bring herself to go
through with it
jim tells her that that was longer than
a heartbeat selena drops the machete and
the two passionately make out hannah
finds them and the three then rush to
frank's car however west who is waiting
for them in the passenger seat shoots
jim in the stomach angered hannah drives
the car and delivers west to the
infected soldier
mailer drags west out and hannah drives
away with selena and jim selena and
hannah take jim to a deserted hospital
selena performs a life-saving operation
on gym and another 28 days pass
jim regains consciousness in a remote
cottage recovered from his injuries in
another room he finds selena sewing
together a large piece of cloth suddenly
hannah comes barging in yelling it's
coming the three grab the fabric and
rush outside in a hurry it is revealed
that it is a large cloth banner reading
the word hello a jet flies by and
notices the sos signal as the trio look
up optimistically
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching